when most people go into a church they
go in there to reflect or to pray
most people i think would admit that
music enhances that experience
there is nothing as moving as the
rumbling of the lowest pitch pipes on
the organ the entire room vibrates with
the sound it's a magical feeling
okay we can start
i'm david wilde i'm the managing
director of henry williston sons
we are organ builders and we build
restore repair and tune
pipe organs all over the british isles
and beyond
henry willis was born in 1821 in london
and set up his own company
as an organ builder in 1845
he built
some of the largest and grandest organs
of the victorian period
until the
industrial revolution
the pipe organ was the most complex
mechanism ever devised the average pipe
organ will have up to 10 000 moving
parts in it
[Music]
a pipe organ has pipes which
sound or speak when air is blown through
the mouth area the speaking length of a
pipe determines the pitch so the
basically the longer the pipe the lower
the pitch the shorter the pipe the
higher the pitch
[Music]
the firm has built somewhere between two
and a half and three thousand organs
in its nearly 175 year history we still
use exactly the same methods some of the
equipment is more up to date but most of
the work is is hand work and we still
use many of the victorian tools that are
still in the firm right from the first
days the skills involved is there's
casting
there's the
metal forming and the soldering
that's just for the pipe making there's
the joinery skills required to make
wooden pipe work that's real skill
[Music]
when i hear one of our organs played in
a big acoustic it can be very moving the
the larger organs have speaking pipes
from a quarter of an inch long
down to 32 feet long
across an entire tunnel and
dynamic spectrum
and there's no better feeling than
standing at an opening recital of a new
organ looking up at it and saying we
made that
[Music]
you